look how bizarre her hand looks normally
it's crazy this is live live footage of
the hands Kendall Jenner shuts down
Photoshop rumors with the help of her
bestie Haley Bieber yeah that's me let's
rewind shall we over the weekend fans
called out the model for allegedly
altering her picks after she shared this
bikini snap to Instagram pointing out
that her hand looks elongated oh my God
just be cool it's fine and while the
haters claimed she photoshopped the
image her famous friends and family
praised her in the comments Kenny's mom
Kris Jenner writing you are perfect and
Addison Ray calling it my favorite post
of yours ever thank you well on
Wednesday Kendall defended the posting
question on Haley Bieber's Instagram
Story look how bizarre her hand looks
normally it's crazy this is live live
footage of the hands Haley captioned the
clip pointing out that Kendall's always
had long hands and fingers look how
bizarre her hand looks normally this is
live live footage of the hands but photo
doctoring rumors are hardly anything new
for Kenny or her famous family it's a
different experience for sure back in
2021 Kendall's Sister Kim Kardashian
shared this snap of what appeared to be
her daughter Chicago and Chloe's
daughter true at Disneyland but Kim's
followers were suspicious of true's
placement in the pick saying it was
giving off a major copy and paste fives
a few months later Coco admitted fans
were right when she took her little girl
to the theme park for her fourth
birthday posting this clip to her insta
story
this is
his first time to Disneyland
yeah you heard that right first time to
Disneyland own whatever it is shortly
after Coco outed her Kim Festa
explaining that the original pick
featured Chicago and Kylie Jenner's
daughter stormy according to Kim Kylie
didn't want her little one posted on
social media that day but the pic was
just too good and perfectly matched
Kim's Instagram aesthetic so Kim swapped
stormy for true and didn't think it
would be that big of a deal you just
gotta roll with it whether it's Kendall
or Kim one thing's for sure the
Kardashian Jenners are gonna talk about
whatever's buzzing online yeah Bible
we're ready for the famous fam to unpack
it all on their Hulu reality series
season 3 is set to Premiere later this
year I love that the episodes are more a
little bit documentary style and I think
that you have a real insight into what
the girls are doing not only you know
what you see in the press or whatever
but what's really happening behind the
scenes before you would see little
Snippets of something and now I think
the episodes are you know Fuller of
content that shows the whole story
[Music]